dear journal its need ugh I may not be
the president yeah on Nickelodeon in the
90s I was the voice of Doug funnie Roger
Klotz ran my timing and Stimpy what a
decade I put a tiny little bit of my own
self into each character
give me a Doug funnie hi everybody this
is Doug funnie oh I got such a crush on
Patti mayonnaise I was pretty much like
that at 11 years old I used to fantasize
a lot you know I could entertain myself
for hours and what about Roger hey
you're the Biggest Loser I ever saw oh
he was based on a bully that used to
bother me how about Wren you shut up you
fool that's a jockey you and Stimpy hey
Ren I picked the nose Goblin I picked it
myself are you
you still entertain yourself I'm sick of
myself
you also do Futurama Philip J fry man
all's constant exposure to radiation is
making me thirsty shut up and take my
money I sounded just like that when I
was 25 I was all whiny nasally and if I
broke a string onstage you know it's
like ah man what I'm gonna do now and
dr. Zoidberg young lady bring me a
sandwich from the dumpster and leave the
maggots on it I'm scheduling Professor
Farnsworth could use everyone I don't
want to live on this planet anymore
stop Brannigan she's a beautiful ship
all right I'm gonna fly her brains out
good I'm very fortunate really lucky
that I can do what I do and I just want
to keep coming to work so I say don't
come in
more it is a final boy ah goodbye